can we talk about the one shot and how
did you do that how do you break it up
or or don't you
so shooting those who walk away in one
take or once one continuous shot was
quite a challenge and we really even
made it harder on ourselves because we
were like well we also want to shoot
during golden hour
so that meant that each day we were
shooting our one shot
we only had one or two goes at it and
then the sun would be too low or too
high and we couldn't match it and so
that was that was really it so it put a
lot of pressure and a lot of stakes on
on each day that we filmed
overall
when you watch the film it reads as one
continuous shot
there's really only a handful of cuts uh
far less than i think people would would
would guess
and um
uh and there's even some you know that
people i
might presume were shot were cuts but
actually aren't
um
but largely we did that to
uh yeah to sort of break up the days and
to you know allow for uh more precision
on um on blocking and camera movements
but if we needed to
um we could have shot the entire thing
in one unbroken cut
we just felt like there would be another
way to kind of have more precision more
sort of hands-on expression of the film
if we broke it up into more or less kind
of 15-minute shots when you compare it
to other you know famous
famous one-shots those are around three
or four minutes long
and we were you know tripling that you
know sometimes four times
and so it was really quite a
quite an obstacle quite a daunting
undertaking and
um i really you know feel like all
filmmakers at some point in their career
should make a one-shot film i really
feel like it's a
an amazing sub genre that
lends so much to engaging in
storytelling in a very unique and
different way
how many production days did it take to
get all of the shots that you needed so
we had about a month of rehearsal and
then a fair amount of
rehearsal and zoom and then some
rehearsal on location and then in total
it was about
um
six or seven production days itself
and basically the format would be we
would rehearse
uh all morning
and then we would just sort of wait and
see when the sun was in the right
position
and then everybody would be on
and we would just try and get as many
takes in as possible
until the sun went down but i was also
very conscious of like if things were
bad in the beginning i had to say cut
very early on or else we wouldn't get a
chance to do a whole other take
so it was it was it was precarious but
um i mean boo boo stewart and scarlett
spurdudo and bryce and john steele and
grant morningstar are actors i mean just
phenomenal and so dependable and really
brought their brought everything you
know to these roles and so we
we never had an issue every single day
we
we
you know we nailed it
so if maybe one line of dialogue was off
or something was off you you stopped it
right away just because it was so
limited for the time you had so anytime
there was dialogue issues we would just
roll with it um
there were there never really were
uh you know there was there was
definitely space for the actors to
improv and and all of that the main
things would be
for example uh the cameraman can't get
in the door quick enough and kind of
hits it and the camera bumps right or
uh there's a car passing and there's a
noise problem and even those subtle
things like we would have okay cut or
you know at the beginning of the film
we basically pass off the shot between
like five or six different um extras and
then cars and then the person on a
bicycle
and if any of those wasn't to my liking
wasn't as precise as i wanted and we
would cut and take it back
and
yeah it was never the actors it was it
was always
you know just the the difficulty of
trying to pull off all these things in
one spot
um in one in one take
and then for the interior shots did that
actually go much smoother you're not
dealing with natural light
the interior shots were just as
challenging and it was you know
working with a kid actor he has to be
wrapped by a certain time so we really
only had again you know one or two goes
at it per day
and on top of that it was such a
small
environment to film in
and
we had to be so conscious of not having
shadows
so
you know the camera person moving 360
degrees around the actor
you know in fight scenes and you know
falling on the ground falling down
stairs i mean so much involved
that
it was just as just as challenging as
you know handing a camera off you know
between three operators as it moves into
a car and then drives for 20 minutes it
was um the house was the house was
was quite challenging but but um yeah
the team was was right there to pull it
off and the exterior of the house was
the same house you were shooting in or
no different same everything was
everything was exactly as as it appears
there were there were really no you know
kind of magic tricks no sets built
um you walk into the house as as we we
we put it all together and um sonia
fault ours our production designer just
did an exquisite job with it and we
largely you know leaned on kind of
german expressionism and
um and ways that sort of reality
distorts within uh you know the real
world and
and
yeah we
we turned that house into so many
different different
uh
uh sort of mindsets of what it is to
experience
um
an interaction with with the villain
rock creep
and that was really a testament to
sonia's vision and and hard work
why did you make the decision to do just
one shot the decision to do one shot is
because i really believe it's a
sub-genre i am i think every director
you know in their canon of work should
have a one shot and
and it just hit me as such a
a daunting challenge that
asking if it was possible on top of
adding these
you know insane uh story elements and
also adding covet onto it um that it
really fired me up to think okay well
let's see let's let's put together you
know
the best people that i've worked with
and
and let's go out there and and see but
there was a there was a huge likelihood
that we wouldn't be able to pull it off
and um
uh it was actually after the first day
uh
most of the cast and crew came to me and
they were like
we saw how confident you were but we
didn't think this was possible like
we're all here but we didn't think this
was possible which is also such a you
know nice gesture for all of them to
like put their trust in me and
um
and but yeah it was funny to hear it i
was like i always i always saw this you
know that's very doable but there was a
lot on the line um
even with uh
with the investors you know i had to
sign that if there was a covet outbreak
and there were financial over overages
that i personally would you know find a
way to to pay those um so it was it was
quite a quite a gamble in a lot of
different ways but um
yeah again just having a phenomenal team
around me i really really believed in
everybody and our ability to get it done
and and
that's the film